we are
facing a new normal in european security
where russia openly contests the
european security order
and uses force
to pursue its objectives
the world will hold russia
and belarus accountable for their
actions
russia
as the aggressor
belarus
as the enabler
president putin's decision to pursue his
aggression against ukraine
is a terrible strategic mistake
for which russia would pay a severe
price for years to come
nato allies and the european union have
already introduced significant sanctions
and many of our partners around the
globe have joined us
we must stand ready to do more
even if it means
we have to pay a price
because we are in this for the long haul
at the same time
the russian people must know
that kremlin's war on ukraine will not
make russia more secure
it will not make russia more respected
in the world
it will not lead
to a better future for your children
in response to russia's massive military
buildup over the past months we have
already strengthened our deterrence and
defense
yesterday
nato allies
activated our defense plans
and as a result we are deploying
elements of the nato response force
on land
at sea and in the air
to further strengthen our posture
and to respond quickly to any
contingency
the united states
canada and european allies
have deployed thousands of more troops
to the eastern part of the alliance
we have over 100 jets
at high lurch
operating in over 30 different locations
and over
120 ships from the high north
to the mediterranean
including
three strike carrier groups
there must be no
space for miscalculation or
misunderstanding
we will do what it takes to protect and
defend every ally and every inch of nato
territory
leaders
today also made clear that we must
continue our support to ukraine
the kremlin is trying to make nato and
the eu provide less support to our
partners
so our collective answer must be more
support
to countries like
georgia
moldova
and bosnia-herzegovina
to help them succeed with their
democratic reforms
and pursue
the path that they have freely chosen
more than ever
this crisis demonstrates the importance
of north america and europe standing
together in nato
there is no security in europe without a
strong transatlantic bomb
with that i'm ready to take your
questions
okay we'll go to al jazeera
james bay's al jazeera
how fearful are you about the possible
fall of kiev how long in your estimate
in your estimation can the government of
ukraine last and if we move to a
resistance insurgency type situation
what support can nato then give
so what we see now is a full-fledged
invasion of ukraine
from multiple directions with air sea
and land capabilities
and this is actually in line with what
our intelligence services predicted over
a long period of time because we saw the
build-up
around ukraine with air sea and land
forces uh we see of course that they're
moving towards uh kiev we also
see uh the rhetoric uh the messages
uh which is strongly indicating that the
aim is to
change government to change
and remove
the democratically elected government in
kiev
we are in close contact with the
government of
ukraine
um we are uh of course monitoring the
situation very closely
um it is still a fluid situation
uh what we have seen is that um the
ukrainian forces are
fighting bravely
and are actually able to
inflict damage
on the invading russian forces
but again it is
a very fluid and
and
an evolving situation
nato allies expressed at the
summit today
that they
provide support to ukraine they are
ready to continue to provide support to
ukraine
uh military support financial support
humanitarian support
and then i think we all have to judge
how things evolves
but the message from
nato leaders and also from
from
from finland and sweden eu
is that we are there to support ukraine
we have support ukraine for many years
and we continue to provide support
we'll go to the national press agency of
ukraine
uh mr national news agency of ukraine
secretary general in the current uh
situation which we observe now in
ukraine
does nato uh preserve its uh desire to
assist ukraine with defensive equipment
in particular observed now in ukraine
does nato uh preserve its uh desire to
um
assist ukraine with defensive equipment
in particular uh can we
expect that nato will provide ukraine
with so badly needed
anti-aircraft equipment thank you so
much so nato allies continue to provide
support to ukraine and was actually at
the meeting today at the
nato summit with eu and finland sweden
allies announced and also
informed other allies about
the type of weapons the type of support
and some of that also includes air
defense systems so so nato allies have
and continue to provide support military
um but also different types of equipment
to ukraine then we all realize that of
course in this very evolving and uh
and uh and uh
difficult situation it's hard to predict
what would be the
what what what are the possibilities in
the future but allies are providing
support and are very committed to
continue to provide support okay we'll
go to nbc just behind the cameras
thank you mr secretary general there's
concern that nato could get pulled into
this conflict if russia were to shut
down electricity or other services
in ukraine that could spill over into
poland or romania can you say explicitly
whether a russian cyber attack of that
nature would trigger an article 5
collective defense
so we are sending a very clear message
to to russia
that we provide support to our
partner
ukraine and allies provide many
different types of support nato help
ukrainians with their cyber defenses
uh
but then for nato allies we provide the
absolute security guarantees
uh under the washington dt article five
an attack on one will be regarded as an
attack on all and we are clear on this
distinction because it is important to
make sure
that um
we don't have
an even bigger crisis in europe
where a russia
challenge or
is threatening
or attacking any nato allied country and
that's the reason why we so clearly send
a message that we are there to protect
all allies and every inch of nato
territory
when it comes to cyber attacks
and the risk for incidents and accidents
in for instance in in the black sea
we are
pursuing
mechanisms of deconfliction
to prevent that from happening
we have as nato allies especially united
states have done that for instance in
syria over a long period of time
and we of course are very focused i
spoke with sarker the
nato supreme commander on that issue
recently and he is very focused on the
need to deconflict to make sure that we
don't have instant accidents that can uh
spiral and get out of control and create
a very dangerous
situation
on cyber
well we have stated that um
cyber attacks can trigger
article five but we have never
uh gone into the
position where we give a potential
adversary the privilege of defining
exactly when we trigger article five we
are focused on strengthening our cyber
defenses we are very much aware of that
that's a risk
uh and uh and therefore we are stepping
up both the protection of our cyber
networks but also providing support
ukraine and we are very focused on the
need for the confliction okay we'll go
to um npr deutsche bank
thank you terry schultz with nprw i want
to know more about the deployment of the
nrf forces please um how many will be
sent where
from where um how long will it take to
get there
thinking about military mobility as
always um and also what has changed in
your calculation about the threat to
nato territory that has led allies to
make the decision to deploy this for the
first time in history for the purposes
of collective defense thank you
well what has changed over the last
days is of course that there's a
full-fledged invasion of a partner
a country that borders several nato
allied countries
and this is the most serious security
crisis we have faced in europe for
decades
and therefore we have the high readiness
force we have the nato response force
and uh that's the reason why we are
deploying it to
again
prevent any miscalculation any
misunderstanding that uh
we are not ready to protect and defend
all allies
and and of course this is something all
allies have agreed to do uh thirteen
hours agreed uh but of course especially
those in eastern part alliance are
extremely concerned
they are close to this uh
uh the fighting in in in ukraine and
they also border russia and have seen
the not only the military buildup and
and the ongoing war in ukraine but also
seen the very threatening rhetoric
because this goes far beyond ukraine
this is about how russia is actually
challenging contesting core values for
our security
and demanding that nato should we draw
all forces
and infrastructure
from almost half of our members
and they stated that if you don't do
that if you don't meet the demands there
will be what they call military
technical consequences so we have to
take this seriously and that's exactly
why
we are now deploying the nato response
force
for the first time
in a collective defense
also
context
and
and we speak about thousands of troops
we speak about air
and maritime
capabilities
they
are already actually part of the
standing naval groups
we have
many
planes
operating in the eastern part of the
alliance
and then several allies
have
partly already assigned troops and
forces to
to the nato response force we have the
lead elements which are led by
by by france we have um
we have the united states which has a
sound assigned thousands of troops to
the nato response force and these will
be deployed to different places in
eastern part of the alliance
well there are part of the coming from
the united states but but these are also
very much european troops
uh
for instance the the lead element the vj
theft the high readiness joint task
force
is now led by by by france
this is a strong german component there
and other allies also part of that
associated press
lawn cook associated press just to
follow up on that secretary general um
the the uh vjtf can only go to one place
and you have eight allies that are
extremely nervous i mean where where
might you
send it have you identified a particular
weakness
on that eastern flank thank you but i
think we have to understand that we have
many uh
elements uh components of the nato
response force
we have increased the redness of the
nato response force and then i don't
speak only about the lead element or the
vjtf the very high readiness joint task
force
but but but we speak about uh uh
more elements than
just that one second we have
allies uh the united states but also
united kingdom and other allies that
have increased readiness of forces
uh that are assigned to nato on the nato
response force
so of course these are additional forces
that we can deploy as part of the
broader deployment of the nato response
force i'm not saying that we are
deploying the whole force the size of
the nato response force has been tripled
since 2014 to roughly 40 000 troops
uh i'm not saying we're deploying the
whole thing i'm saying that we are
deploying elements elements of the
leader
also the vjtf and elements of the rest
of the nato response force and and then
it is for sakura to make fine decisions
exactly where the different elements are
deployed but we activated the defense
plans yesterday
and
and
now
uh the elements
of this force will be uh deployed or
yeah this team is being deployed okay
we'll go to tv2
lady and white
lady and white over there
thanks uh alien social
tv2 norway i'll just follow up on ap and
what terry from npr said how
quick can these
troops
and this force be
deployed
but some of these forces are already
operating because we have sea and air
forces which are also all the part of
the nato maritime forces operating from
the balance down to the mediterranean
some are air forces
the air component of the nato response
force and then some of the land forces
are
also can move within a few days
uh because they are part of either the
lead element um which has already high
redness or the other elements that has
been put on high redness
so we speak about pace and some are
already
operating
because we have increased our presence
already
okay we'll try to take a couple of
questions online uh we'll go first to
frankfurt
thomas
thanks a lot good afternoon secretary
general in the statement that has just
been released
um it is said that russia's actions are
flagrant rejection of the principles
enshrined in the nato-russia founding
act and then it continues it is russia
that has walked away from its
commitments under the act
does
that mean that nato now considers the
nato-russia founding act as obsolete
or do nato member states still
are they still bound do they still feel
bound by this document thanks a lot
the nato leaders decided today a
statement very clearly state
the fact that russia has walked away
the nato-russia founding act
is based on some core principles
enshrined in the founding act and that
is
the respect for uh
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
all
countries including of course ukraine
and this has been violated not once but
twice
and has actually been constantly
violated violated since 2014 with the
illegal annexation of crimea and the
continued presence of russian forces and
russian-backed separatists in eastern
ukrainian donbass and this is further
violated
with the full-fledged invasion of
ukraine that we have seen over the last
couple of days
um so so so what we have what we see
is that russia show no respect for the
nato russia founding act and of course
if you have a founding act between two
partners
nato and russia and one part doesn't
respect that agreement
that the agreement doesn't work
it doesn't function it doesn't
help us to improve our relationship with
the with with russia because even if the
founding act has good provisions and uh
and good intentions
if these uh intentions and the
provisions and the and the founding act
is not respected it doesn't work so
that's the reality the nato for uh nato
russia founding act
doesn't work because one side russia has
violated it over many years but now is
here
extremely
blatant uh
and flagrant flagrant violation of the
founding out with the invasion of
ukraine
we'll take the next question online also
from greg palket from fox
thank you wanna thank you mr secretary
general uh two quick questions one about
war one about peace do you agree with
some reports of intelligence officials
that kiev could fall within the next say
day or two and despite the bravery of
the fighting that you have cited among
ukrainian soldiers
do you see a defeat inevitable if war
goes on and the quick question about
peace there is discussion
uh president zielinski offering to
discuss with russia
an approach to peace that might include
neutrality for
ukraine would you agree to something
like that
thank you
the first on the situation
on the ground
um
it is a full invasion of ukraine um
they are moving towards kiev
and the stated goal is to
change the government of ukraine
[Music]
it is a very
unpredictable situation therefore i'm
not re
speculate but i will pay my respect
to the
ukrainian armed forces
which are really
proving their bravery and
their courage by
fighting and standing up against
the much larger invading russian
force
on potential talks between
the government of ukraine
president silency and
russia
my main message is that this is for
president silence and the government of
of ukraine to decide
what we
what we need to see now is that russia
stop the attack against ukraine that
they withdraw their forces and cease
all the
attacks on ukraine that's the
the easiest the fastest and the best way
to peace
so if they want uh
peace then it's just stop to attack
ukraine
and therefore call on russia to do
exactly that
okay we'll go to ntv
yes
from ntv secretary general two short
questions first you're a statistician
and so far with regard the risk you have
already evaluate
the the risk and the threat against nato
coming from russia particularly you you
foresee the playbook of russia and so my
first question is
what is the risk that this conflict
spread
uh
where and what might be the end goal of
russia and my second question is you
have at the top of your the tip of your
fingers
the security of one billion
citizen in the transatlantic area so you
met with on vtc all the leaders can you
reassure the public opinion that
if there is a genuine threat coming from
because the rhetoric the aggressive
rhetoric of russia its behavior is
unacceptable that all member states are
committed to defend and protect every
single centimeter of
nato thank you
in the meeting today with nato leaders
it was a very strong
message of unity a very strong message
of resolve that we need to stand
together
not only in words but also in deeds
so we agreed a strong statement
calling on russia to stop
the attacks on ukraine to withdraw its
forces
but also uh we agreed to continue to
provide support to ukraine and also
continue to strengthen our presence in
eastern part alliance
to prevent
any attack on any nato allied country
we have a defensive presence in the east
we
are
increasing our presence not to provoke a
conflict but to prevent the conflict and
as long as there is no doubt about
nato's readiness to protect and defend
all allies
and our commitment to the core message
the core task of nato one for all for
one an attack on one ally will be
regarded as an attack on all
then no ally will be attacked and that
will prevent the conflict
uh and that will preserve peace for nato
allies and for one billion people
um and that's the reason why we
communicate so clearly and that's the
reason why we are deploying more troops
in the eastern part of the lions
to make sure that there is no
possibility to misunderstand
uh our readiness to protect and defend
all allies and again this is to pursue
peace to prevent an attack
and to prevent
that the war which is going on in
ukraine
um
spill over to any nato other country
and uh and that's that that was the
message from nato leaders today
uh that was also the message when i met
with many of them in the g7
uh yesterday
and that is also of course a message
when we speak to close partners finland
sweden and the european union because we
all are concerned and russia's attack on
ukraine is
more than an attack on ukraine it said
it's a devastating horrendous attack on
innocent
people in ukraine but there's also an
attack on the whole european security
order and that's the reason why we take
it so extremely seriously
uh deutsche bank
thank you alexander from nam deutsche
secretary general one question on on
ukraine's request
for turkey to to close the bosphorus to
for russian warships is that be and was
that discussed today and one follow-up
on the question just asked
we heard today from the lithuanian
foreign minister saying that when we
lose ukraine today we will be fighting
for nato later
would you say that the statement is
exaggerated
thank you
so on on the bosphorus that was not an
issue um uh on uh on um
on uh uh
the potential attack or any potential
attack on the nato other country well
that has been our message throughout the
whole day that was the message from the
nato leaders in the summit today
is that is that
is that we are there to protect and
defend all allies nato is the strongest
military alliance in the world
and make no mistake we are there to
protect and defend all allies and every
inch of nato territory and we convey
that message again and again
both in words but also in deeds
and uh and that's the way to prevent the
war that's when to prevent an attack
to preserve peace and we have done so
for more than 70 years and will continue
to do it also in the light of
the attack on
ukraine
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference
thank you so much